citizens of the reject Nation we have made it
to the final episode of season one of Reacher
but there's something very important I must
communicate to each and every one of you who
have been watching with us this entire time there
are still so many words that rhyme with Reacher
that we have yet to force into our reactions
yes this is our last opportunity so if you were
annoyed by it prior if you thought wow they're
really trying way too hard to be funny with words
that rhyme with Reacher get ready for it because
we are doubling down did I prepare words prior
no but we'll see what comes out of my mouth
when we're watching this so you know what
to do reach for that like button people and if
you haven't subscribed why not why not tell me
you don't have to subscribe just tell me
why you haven't subscribed also I want to
say a massive thank you to everyone who has
joined us on our patreon via dish this show
alone who has done full-length reaction
watch-alongs We sync up with your own
copy of Reacher that is for a super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page and we cover
so many things with exclusively reaction
highs and watch alongers included are you
ready to become Jack reactor today yes I am
Jack uh reaching for a rhyme right now damage
[Music]
oh Jack Trader try anything smart I'm
gonna put a hole right in your pals back
Jack feeler
I thought you were my friend I was that's
why I told you not to take the job down here
Jack beseecher you and this they couldn't let
things go where's Roscoe oh my girls doing just
fine oh tied up they want me to tell you to do
what they say or me Charlie and the kids they're
gonna do to us but they didn't Morrison cut off
their testicles [Music] he's on the Run thought
getting lost to protect his family yeah exactly
thought it your father promised some real bad
guys overseas a hefty amount of counterfeit cash
but thanks to the Coast Guard blockade those boys
haven't gotten what they paid for in a while so
they sent some Venezuelan hitters to help you
pretty soon those Venezuelans are going to
give you the same necktie they gave your daddy
shut up I killed my father oh damn we
was right whoa yeah I killed Joplin
I had that [__] killed in the
subway woof I killed your brother
[Music] smash him now we got a main villain yeah
you're gonna take Picard to wherever hubbles hold
up and you're gonna bring him to me now how do you
expect me to do that you're a Tracker aren't you
check tracker find him then I'll trade mommy and
the girls for Daddy track Reacher I don't know how
you think I'm gonna find Hubble well yeah until
sunrise tomorrow so I suggest you figure it out
I need a map and a place to think Jack Navigator
what can I get you fellas black coffee peach pie
nothing for me it's finally gonna get that pie
give me a pen you expect me to hand you something
you can use as a weapon this scare you I hope he
uses it I hope to God he uses it wax Reacher on
the map Reacher so we ran off to Atlanta about
an hour from margrave Big City lots of people
makes it easy to hide Athens it's hard for a man
if he's halfway decent to leave his family behind
it's home to University of Georgia where
Paul and Charlie went to college it's a
place directly linked to Hubble so Augusta
is next over three hours away but still
close enough he feels connected to his wife
and kids but first he moved to Wisconsin
oh [__] he can't just steer into
something and get inside a man's
head like that I didn't offer
my help you [__] demanded it
from the fork give me the fork
four creature that's what I'm
talking about you better be right about Augusta
Jack puncture we should reserve it
for when we can do a full rhyme of
course anything we could go Jack Diner
if we wanted that works that's not bad
you gotta say he lived tougher than I thought you
were and you're exactly what I thought you were
oh he's been getting his ass kicked more than
anyone else in this show poor Finley deserves
a vacation got a flat no way we make it to Augusta
you being cute you've been with me the whole time
laughs beautiful delivery you think I'm gonna
leave you alone here while I go and change the
damn thing get to work oh he knows I mean
you know there's like a title and if you're
thinking about throwing a tire in my direction
think again yeah the Fork's still in my plan
you shoot me I ain't the only
person you're killing yes I
didn't think that through but if you
shoot me you're never finding Hubble
Dan's right so on one we raise our guns up over
our heads on two we lay them on the trunk I know
what a gun hit metal sounds like so don't
you [__] with me and on three we stand up
and face each other hands up then I take two
steps back and you come get my piece whoo one
two
three wow yep yep yep yep Jack manipulators
hello Hubble and we found the
exact room and everything yeah
if I was Hubble I would stay in room
number seven at this exact Motel [Music]
ladies somebody says me your daddy's caused
us a lot of problems did you know that
my daddy's gonna kick your ass
don't do this but I have to because you and your
friends are troublemakers you don't have to just
like the old pal gray was a troublemaker we'll
keep them someplace safe his insurance things go
smoothly everyone who is suspiciously a bad guy
is a bad guy I know in a weird way it's kind of
refreshing how did you find my motel I use credit
cards and Kleiner finds you so you use cash which
means travel by bus well how'd you guess my Alias
people use the names of things they like their
plan is to kill all of us just like they killed
my brother your treasury contact Mark Salas that's
just the name he gave you real name's Joe played
for the Yankees in the late 80s I was trying to
figure out who it was but I would never guess that
KJ kill Joe a kid kill Joe and Morrison Stevenson
and his wife even killed his own father real
crazy cat [Music] if somebody's texting you buddy
what does that mean you're an idiot oh
Jack steamer
I hope you're transferring Finley
yeah seriously
like the way you die boy oh it's good to see you
alive what's at the gun lock or the ammo safe
grab anything useful I was never able to
get replacement glasses huh no it's the one
thing they could track them the prescription oh I
want to give him a gun he won't be able to shoot
properly no Hubble needs all the guns this place
have a hose out back yeah why we're gonna need it
I'm thirsty boss Neely this
is Finley and Hubble yes
probably holding Roscoe and Charlie somewhere
around here what about my kids probably up
here I'll come up in there you don't have to
waste a man watching them what if they ruin
your office their Ideal World Hubble and I get
marched through the front door and they kill
all of us they put guns outside and probably
doesn't mean inside arm to the teeth in case
I somehow go on guns blazing which what do
we do don't go in blazing that's what I'm
talking about man I've never fired a gun all
you got to do is extend Aim Fire no point in
having a weapon unless it's ready for instance
use if you hesitate you die Point elsewhere
siphon [Music]
Jack prayer are you Catholic yeah Jack Preacher oh
no I was reserving that oh
the only one I ever served
we can edit it out it's looking for
like some monologue or something
damn you got 20 minutes to come
up with a new one yeah I got one
left you know it's hard to tell with the
suit on but you're kind of jacked Finley
really no there's no need to body shaming
yeah he's a competent guy all right he's
fitted enough not your size that's mean
not everyone's a cancel Jack Reacher Jacob
apologize Jack shamer man I like it damn it
did the preacher was the only one I was like
waiting for the right time same the other one
I'm not gonna be able to use I don't see it
coming up pretty sure enough I should be in
place by now really even goes to take one
of the shots two Shooters better odds you have
experience with long range kill shots you know
why I do I offer Wowie put the biscuit in the
basket put the lotion in the basket [Applause]
they're gonna make like a giant Molotov
out of that yeah wait I got this
ah oh I'm gonna die I wanna
flavor country one last time
yeah keep up with those Joneses
how are we gonna die let's find out
nice Finley Finley flick Oscar flamely
you got this buddy is that
improvised it looked very natural
[Music]
oh yeah draft [Music]
gun is so tiny on him so cute cute little gun
damn look at these HD cameras these Reds
I always tell the motion of a red camera
[Applause] yes yes [Music]
shot yeah oh no he actually shot one of his kids
the lock is sticking out of one of their faces
great shot adrenaline not that easy to shoot
it's a real satisfying action finale
[Music]
are your testicles okay
oh [__]
camo when a woman doesn't
want to be touched [Music]
this mother who made it back I said to shoot him
again yeah Jesus you walk the whole way [Music]
I was just shoot at the air condition
it's probably you know there's probably
nothing in there except pretty thin paper
push oh yes everyone gets The Showdown
they deserve that's right where's
this cane at bash him in the brain
oh no no Finley
these cuts throw the money
in his face pocket money yeah
put your whole fist in there you've
been terminated [Music] oh my God
that was very satisfying she's just trying
to get on his back this whole time no no
don't [__] do that shoot him in the ass
whoa dumbass where is he I gotta go get richer
he'll be okay how do you know that because
he's richer he breathes smoke like this on his
spare time just in case a situation like this
should arise to go real fire everywhere definitely
real flights this was a dangerous shoot you guys
let me tell you a story Jack a couple years ago
I'm on Safari in the savannah I spot this big
old rhinoceros allowing him to track you boy
do you know that for sure
big dumbass it's not real sport that stupid
Rhino wasn't smart enough to realize he
was over yes yes let's go Jack feeder Jack
feeder [Music] this guy's still talking yeah
foreign
[Music]
went from Jack speecher to Jack screamer [Music]
he survived
you've earned that shot show and Money
Shot For Real no counterfeit he never
got to have that pie I know maybe in the
last scene he'll get it to go through the
bus rider oh look at that the love
Jack lover Jack passionate Reacher
oh don't be a jack lever
Jack sleazer Jack's loser hey that's
a good one [Applause] oh Jack squeezer
a few minutes left in the show yeah
[Laughter] something for Jack Cleaver in
the five minutes maybe when he gets the pie
well there's some Jack cleavages the bed right now
one last flashback let's go come over
Joe okay I'm okay John
um no matter what you don't You Know Jack Tierra
oh Jack feeler I can get you to the states to see
experts what did I always tell you I don't need
to solve all the world's problems and the Richer
you have the strength of three men plus two your
Natures are pure like your hearts check nature
your grandfather's War medal got it
held it up his ass two years [Laughter]
it takes bravery to do what's right
he does it like fearlessly now you can cry Reacher
whoa what a defined here yeah if you ever find
yourself wandering by here again give me a call
oh finally got her number Jack rapper oh my
God all the people who killed Jack Reaper Jack
Reaper never go there and he's dressed in black he
should run for mayor here there's an opening bando
yes man that's a bummer they're so lovely
together I like the attention detail that
she's still got the yeah the cuff bruise
I want 10 slices of peach pie give me a
repeat pie you have is that the author of the
book must be played like a special Cameo yeah
so feds are freaking out because of a car's
involvement and all they want to interview you
what'd you tell them that they'll never find you
but they're still in town down by the warehouse
and you kind of stand out so I'll be gone as
soon as we're done here not gonna miss you
don't bother calling I'm gonna stay here a
few weeks help Rosco get things in order and
then I'm going home time to stop spinning
stop running away you know Sharon would
want me to live a life and not live it alone
you're here that girl coming back I think I'm
ready to take care of someone again let's go
besides I couldn't leave Jack in the shelter
Jack yeah he needed a name and you weren't
using it reach yourself Jack it is one of my
last official access Chief detective you
were fired a dead mess I didn't stick so
I need to right or wrong that took place at
this very spot about a week and a half ago
the pie the pie I hope he hates it I've
had better of course you of course you have
and grab some crayons and kill them
oh for Joe died yeah
takes bravery to solve The World's
problems too Joe boy [Music]
you're gonna ask for a car yeah there's got
to be one burner at that compound at least
go back to the garage where you got that guy's
uh van doesn't say if there's a guest appearance
by Lee Childs here uh let's see let's find out
this is the child lead just the one child like
Julia Child all right what we'll do is this we'll
just Google oh wait they're not gonna tell us we
have to go to IMDb or Google if we want to know
look up what his name is Lee Child yeah yeah
looks like him yeah oh look at there
he is with Thomas Cruz yeah that's
definitely him yeah right yeah let's
just type it in reach her episode 8.
yeah well done Blaze like it I know it's
like this place there are only two reasons
you play it like that one is if he's a secret
Hitman and two as if he wrote the novels yeah
which way is this one gonna yeah [Music]
perfect perfect sauce very satisfying that
was a very satisfying finale and it earned all
the tropes you would want in a show like this I
thought every Trope was viciously earned right
down to the opening monologues from everyone
deciding to explain their plan to the one guy
they shouldn't explain their whole plan too out
of anyone who you especially need them to do a
solid for them yeah ask for them to cooperate
probably shouldn't reveal the whole plan
but we needed the information and we got
there right down to the villain reveal oh
I mean we've got several villain reveals
but you know what I mean the ultimate villain
reveal yeah needed that and then of course the
action set piece at the very end uh they built
to everything in a way that had that release
yeah cathartic yes that that John's favorite
word of the century oh yeah hey man when you
when you find it you gotta call it out catharsis
is hard to come by you say it every video I know
because every video so how hard is to
be very cathartic this is such a release
I'm just drained every day from
the amount of release of tension
uh the great catharsis of that fight yes um
because a lot of times when you get to finales
like that so I shouldn't showed some mystery heavy
oh man it just big actions that was worth it that
was rewarding it was a good action the show has
it's got this cool realistic take it's not like
quite born identity type of fighting that's a
little bit more hyper choreographed yeah here
has a a good mix of they got like real Marines
and army people involved or something to help
out with the choreography of like how would
they move and fight you could feel like the
really good training yeah it's tactical it's a
good realism hence I like it I liked it a lot
um the arcs of these characters was great and
did not feel rushed I thought it actually built
to a really solid conclusion and let's have we
gotta wait now we gotta wait we got some time
to wait no I can't wait I this was such a nice
surprise I really loved this and yeah it felt
very well-rounded and I too appreciate a mystery
that can build a lot of its you know ultimate
conclusions you know I feel like any Mystery
Show often is like working overtime to throw
you off the scent and like give you a million red
herrings and stuff like that and I never felt them
like working too hard to do that and like like you
pointed out most of the people responsible like
Picard is kind of a Twist but most of the people
responsible are the people who were suspected and
it's more about like how deep did this go and what
is the context and what is the Journey of solving
the mystery and ultimately you know bringing the
truth to light and uh and yeah I appreciated that
because I don't know just like most Mysteries uh
kind of I think give you this outside especially
crime Mysteries this outset thing of like I'm
I'm going to suspect the least on obvious person
because they're I know they're trying to outsmart
me and I felt like this wasn't weighed down by
that no yeah not at all and uh great characters
I mean I loved everybody like Reacher is like the
perfect centerpiece and even as he's leaving town
I'm like I'm excited to see him interact with a
new cast of characters but I loved Roscoe and I
loved Finley and uh and even you know supporting
characters like Hubble and Christian cruick and
all that stuff like nice presents especially
Kristin cruick sure nailed it sure she was the
highlight yeah so many scenes every scene every
moment was like on screen you don't have to put
her in Everly scene just because she agreed to
do the show guys calm down and Roscoe was amazing
Never Gonna forget that character yeah Finley and
uh I don't know if you guys have seen the Lethal
Weapon movies but there's a bit of a Lethal Weapon
Vibe between the two and then we gotta see Joe
sure with his hair in the morgue I mean Joe I
don't know who that actor is who played Joe
yeah I don't know if my mind was just doing
it because of what we saw his head look like in
the morgue but I was going that actor looks like
he's wearing a wig is he actually balding and he
wears wigs but because that's a really good set
of 80s cocaine Wall Street Hair he's got sure yeah
definitely I would be curious to know I I hadn't
thought of it in the moment but uh that's a good
question because that actor with that chiseled of
a face I'm like no no he would have a good set
of hair who played Joe in Reacher let's see a
good set of hair this guy yeah they just wanted
you to think it was a wig as a character choice
in here he looks great like like all these all
these photos his hair looks amazing yeah but
um yeah that that strong hairline uh yeah no
he's uh he's a handsome fella he's got a he's
got a total um you know not Norman Bates what's
his name Patrick Patrick Bateman thing about him
oh yeah he does look like Alan Richardson yeah
yeah they both got that that strong jaw you know
and that All-American built guy kind of thing
but you can definitely too see how you know
Joe wound up working where he works versus Jack
doing what he does you know he's a little bit
more working with the mind and with the system
than Jack who's a little bit more working with
his hands well they've been building up Joe for so
long like he's put on such a pedestal of the kind
of amazing god-like human being that he is that to
happen to cast an actor in there he needs someone
who can communicate that the second you see him
and I thought they did that like the second he
walked up to him like that's got to be Joe who
did apparently gain weight and go bald yeah I
guess so well you know he maybe he was undercover
maybe they were like people will suspect me less
if I look like a schlub yeah now let's rewatch
the Jack Reacher movie honestly like I'm curious
to see what it's because like I remember the
tones generally and I remember being like okay
this is like a Tom Cruise joint that goes a
little bit hard uh but yeah like I would love
to catch the nuances in comparison to this I had
a really famous car chase yes that was like what
it was mainly noted for was its car chase sequence
yeah and for giving us Jai Courtney he's also very
practical that sequence um yeah so that was a good
moment and the resolve that Finley comes around
the dog there's a lot of great things in here
yeah a lot of nice Tire rounds the card Ultimate
Survivor well that was a kill boy that was that
was uh that was hard yeah but Full Sail crushed
uh that sounds a total psycho yeah oh God
they're just like monologuing through the
thing and then Jack got to use the animal
feed even that got paid off in a fun way
yeah and uh Neely Great Character hope we see
I mean I imagine we'll see Neely again it's
the one person and I'm excited and I like
that Neely got a piece of the action too
uh you know watching the perimeter getting into
a scuffle even Hubble got a headshot it's like
it's not that easy to shoot dude yeah we have
no experience and especially when it's burning
building through glass with your kids next day
one shot it took yeah I'll I'll give it to him
but also yeah that one moment where I was like
I feel like if it was me and I was I was putting
the seed together I just wouldn't make it a direct
like third eye headshot I would have made it like
three shots at least yeah yeah a few shots couple
misses and yeah it's like maybe he's in like the
throat or like some place off but that still gets
the job done yeah I just I've always kind of I
find it funny when they're like no we're gonna do
the perfect headshot you know yeah that was great
but yeah all around a terrific Terrific show you
gotta Burn It All To The Ground by the end yeah oh
man it's gonna I have to readjust this is like uh
this is like um uh oh man pulling names these days
is so hard for me I learned too many things that
I forget too much so much what's his name Blanche
gonna have a same centerpiece but different
characters yeah I like that mystery solving
and then with some action scenes I just hope next
season isn't just like let's go double the action
this time yeah I thought they spread it out really
nice I feel like in a way you don't have to change
the general approach I think it's more about
yeah did you find a new crime and you find a new
interesting setting and maybe some kind of other
musical artist to flavor the I don't know I mean
I guess it'll always be Blues because what Jack
likes but but yeah I feel like you don't need to
force it into being like an action extravaganza
the atmosphere is part of the draw you know I'm
so happy this Show's a success because I had no
faith in it when it was announced oh because they
had the movie it just seemed like such a downgrade
on from Optics perspective you know what I mean
to go from one of the biggest superstars in the
Galaxy you know biggest superstars in the world
I mean that second film was terrible yeah it was
never go back and watch that show um that was a
terrible second film and then to go to a like
we're going to make a television show with an
actor who's is nowhere near as no yeah yeah yeah
um I did not have faith in its announcement like I
don't really care about this I'm sure book readers
are excited like hey there's probably gonna do a
more accurate version It's a book you know I'm
sure they had a lot more reasoning behind it but
I I just wasn't as someone who's not familiar
with the source material yeah yeah but they
nailed it they they totally outdid the movie oh
100 yeah I think they totally outdid it and this
is definitive and to me I don't even really want
to watch the ah watch the first one again probably
um uh yeah I mean I would only watch never go
back again as some kind of morbid curiosity I
mean Kobe smolders she threw down for that movie
like I respected what she she tried to do with
it but uh but the first movie is like pretty all
right is is I remember liking it and being kind of
surprised that I pretty much liked it but I wonder
if the movie hadn't come out because the Movie
allowed so many more people to be aware of Jack
Reacher like the second I heard reach her I was
like is this Jack Reacher yeah totally totally
that I wonder if it's still somehow aided in
getting the show done well yeah I wonder if it's
a two-fold thing of people going like okay well
Tom yeah Tom Cruise obviously made this a thing
people might be aware of and also on the heels of
that you have everyone who's been reading these
books now causing a pretty you know just being
pretty vocal and apparent about like these movies
may be fun but they're not really like the book
yeah you know and and I think that opportunity is
is one that is pretty vital in this day and age
when you're I feel like it's the better version
of constantly drawing from what's familiar it's
like okay what was what was all right but could
be more essentially what it's supposed to be yeah
something like this and and two I mean yeah
it's like Alan Richardson when we learned his
name through this experience but that too allows
it to just be the character which is a nice thing
so it doesn't have to you know you don't have
to vacuum form Jack Reacher onto Tom Cruise
amazing stuff guys I thought they nailed it
thought it was an amazing show give it a 10
out of 10. 10. 10 out of 10 even for sleazeball
villain I would not find to be a real threat
I thought for a second he could be when he took
you know when it's revealed that he did all that
stuff but then when it's he's at the end and
he's just like just going around and telling
his long-ass story and uh like nah you ain't
[__] brother I I don't I hope that for the
next season it that they give him Again full names
today um I use it all on trying to find words that
rhyme and reach her uh what is Sherlock Holmes's
arch nemesis oh Moriarty Moriarty he needs like
a Moriarty for next season yeah someone who can
match his intelligence sure and then who has maybe
like a military background as well or something
like that who can no served with him there you go
yeah it's his jigsaw of the Punisher or whatever
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they need to make
it that kind of villain where it's a it's a cat
it's a true cat and mouse game I think like even
if whatever book They're adapting I think whoever
their main villain is has to be someone with a
much more Superior intelligence that would make
sense yeah somebody who somebody yeah who pushes
Jack thinks closer to how he thinks because yeah
everyone here has they have this operation and
they certainly are formidable but they don't think
the same way you think because the fear of stakes
that really of the life or death Stakes like of
course Jack Reacher would never die of course
Watson I know you're sad that the reacher show
was done but don't attack the other cats there
will be season two they're done shooting I think
so soon enough um uh uh what are we talking about
oh Jack needs a Moriarty moving forward um wasn't
about Mel Gibson no Mel Gibson uh he should be
on the show though yeah I think he could be the
villain everyone would love it uh something about
oh yeah the life or death Stakes they really
come in to the fear for The Supporting Cast
not really worried about Jack I mean not that
I it's a tall order to ask like of course like
you'd be aware but I like this I like a good
show when when you're like of course they're
not gonna die but you like to feel like in the
moment it's really threatening you know that
yeah you want that tension yeah yeah you always
feel safest around Jack and I do think they still
manage I think they managed to ring tension out
of like what's he gonna decide because some like
you know in that standoff with uh Picard you know
you're sort of like you're sort of expecting he's
gonna kill him but at the same time I was like oh
and I kind of don't know how this is gonna go um
but yeah yeah having it having us worry for Jack
at least a little bit is would be good alrighty
guys well what did you think about Reacher what
would you give it out of 10 out of 10 what would
you give it I give it a 9.8 ah I give it a 9.853
wow yeah talk about catharsis that is a cathartic
rating I haven't had an 8.593 in a long time 9.8
whatever it's a good show my shout someone out
I would like to shout out Andrew Hayes Andrew
Hayes you could totally see becoming like a Jack
Reacher John will find a way to insert the lock
mechanic business that he is in he could get in
any building there he's found really fast yeah
you get into any building disabled the alarms
and all that stuff there you go yeah that's one
aspect but at the same time Andrew being a three
foot five stocky fella yeah never watches the
channel or checks his bank account to see if
he's still on board for his patreon pledge hasn't
changed in one bit nope appreciate you being here
Andrew the most consistent investor and if
there's anyone who could bulk up the fastest
to get a body like Jack Reacher it's definitely
going to be Andrew oh you'd have the muscle of
Alan richson and the height of Tom the perfect
Middle Ground between both characters teach us
all to survive the crime apocalypse perfect third
Reacher all around well Andrew thank you so much
for being here please don't ever check your
bank statements and hey shout you out again
next month and you'll have no idea that we did
it someday you're gonna find just an avalanche
foreign